the image the family have chosen
celebrates the smile that was her
trademark
Westminster Abbey is set to welcome the
world including her great-grandchildren
nine-year-old Prince George and
seven-year-old princess Charlotte will
be part of this most public funeral
their grandfather King Charles will lead
the nation he said
as we all prepare to say our lust
farewell I wanted simply to take this
opportunity to say thank you to all
those countless people who have been
such a support and comfort to my family
and myself in this time of grief
last night the nation paused once again
the final hours of lying in state
included a visit from U.S President Joe
Biden
as I've told the king
she's going to be with him every step of
the way every minute every moment world
leaders and overseas royalty have
invitations as do people from across the
UK who have just made a difference like
Kim Hughes one of the finest bomb
disposal experts the British army has
ever seen I don't think it's about just
being in the Abbey absolutely humbled at
the fact that I've had that invitation
but I I don't think it's just about the
people in the area I think it's about
the country coming together to remember
the life of the queen
Westminster Abbey has hosted Royal
funerals for nearly a thousand years
and was Central To Her Majesty's life
it's where she got married and it's
where her coronation took place and if
you're in any doubt as to how big this
all is well it's expected to be the
world's most watched broadcast of all
time
clear the route they've even taken down
some traffic lights many camped here
overnight to see and feel this spectacle
we've got some roses to like throw and
we're just gonna
to watch our Queen yes easily arguable
that she is definitely the greatest you
know British woman but not maybe the
British British person to ever I've ever
lived really
the day will conclude at Her Majesty's
beloved Windsor Castle and a private
burial in Saint George's Chapel
her coffin will be lowered into the
Royal Vault alongside Prince Philip
theirs is a tour of Duty that we will
never see again
Tom palminter Sky News